[Music]
all right
what can I say gaming phones have come a
long way since they first started coming
out a few years ago not just because
there's more gaming phones and that's
more competition but also just because
regular Flagship phones now have insane
Hardware too but still at the top of the
Heap for gaming phones sits this guy the
Asus Rog Phone 7 Ultimate let's just
start with just the numbers okay numbers
on paper Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 at 3.2
gigahertz with the adreno 740 GPU
16 gigs of lpddr5x RAM half a terabyte
of ufs 4.0 storage a 6.78 inch 1080p
AMOLED display at 165 Hertz up to 1200
nits a 6 000 milliamp hour battery with
65 watt charging and two usb-c ports
plus a headphone jack kind of sounds
like it has everything because it nearly
does but I actually do want to start
with the one thing that it doesn't have
which is a a world-class camera system
but the thing is I mean that's probably
fine it is a gaming phone after all now
obviously it's still expensive so you
don't want to feel like you're getting a
bad camera but let's be real the camera
is not the priority in these phones or
for the people buying these phones so I
mean really the objective is to give you
a good enough camera system that you're
not mad but it's not going to be a good
enough camera that you're out bragging
about it so this is a 50 megapixel
primary camera that bends to 12 and a
half megapixels and can do that lossless
2x zoom and then there is a 13 18
megapixel Ultra wide and that third
camera is a 5 megapixel macro so not a
telephoto it's all fine right it's a
it's a pretty classic like daylight
shots decent lighting is fine and then
as soon as the lighting conditions
deteriorate so do the photos and videos
you get a lot of noise pretty quickly I
still got to give props to Asus for
doing a pretty great job with HDR though
and getting a good amount of detail out
of most normal shots and they've
actually even added some pretty clever
features to their default camera app and
I don't think of Asus phones usually as
like the best cameras ever but there's
the pro photo and video modes that are
getting you a few new features to play
with that are just like fun to use so
combined with the 32 megapixel selfie
camera I feel like I can confidently
give this whole camera Suite like a b
it's definitely not bad it's just it's
not why you buy this phone I mean if
you're looking for the reason you buy
this phone look no further than the
design because that says everything you
need to know this is the Phantom white
finish on the back here still the this
year it's a combination of satin white
and I guess a different satin white
maybe matte white but it still has the
text everywhere Rog O7 Republic of
Gamers 206 8K Ultra HD the ultimate
version still has this display on the
back which you can't even see while
you're using the phone but it will
display to the people around you either
in animation or some information in a
scrolling Banner or when it's face down
and charging you can see your percentage
things like that you can't have too big
of a camera up like you have these
gigantic camera Rings now and a lot of
these Flagship phones you can't do that
on this phone because it's supposed to
be perfectly balanced for when you're
you're gaming and holding it in
landscape mode and so that's why you
have that split battery design 3000
milliamp hours over here 3000 more
milliamp hours over here and actually
the motherboard is in the middle which
is a pretty clever design and so now
it's
perfectly balanced
as all things should be now like I said
gaming phone right so we have these
awesome Flagship phones s23 Ultra Oppo
Find X6 Pro they also have incredible
numbers and specs but this one separates
itself by leaning a little bit more
towards gaming and media and that
experience not that those aren't good at
gaming in media but well gaming is Media
so the things that this does to be good
at gaming are great at that and watching
videos and just sort of scrolling around
using a phone like normal so that's why
you end up with not just 120 hertz ltpo
but a Samsung built flat 165 Hertz OLED
with a 720 Hertz touch sample rate and a
23 millisecond touch latency it's once
again the most responsive and smoothest
display I've ever used in a phone my eye
can actually tell the difference between
this and 120hz display and a lot of the
other flagships out right now which is
awesome so that's of course going to be
great for gaming getting every single
last frame out of the games that
actually support that but also that's
pretty nice for just scrolling around
and flipping through apps and social
media too this split battery setup
they've got going on they've been doing
that for a couple years too 3 000 plus
3000 is a 6 000 milliamp hour battery
and that actually allows them to fast
charge them in parallel so you get 65
Watts going into the phone it'll charge
from zero to 100 in like 45 minutes
which is already 10 minutes faster than
last year's phone and they even have
this graphic uh that they sent me
showing the standard batteries need a
thin separator while fast charging
battery is made a thicker separator
because they push more current and it's
just safer to do it this way sounds like
this would be a trade-off that you have
to think really hard about in any other
phone except it doesn't matter in this
phone because the whole phone is thick
it's thick enough to handle a gigantic
battery and fast charging I mean that's
that's at least three C's you know plus
there's a whole Suite of battery
management features that make this thing
last forever I mean it's already a
battery champ easily pulling seven hours
of screen on time at 165 Hertz but
there's also scheduled charging there's
also study charging so it doesn't fast
charge every time you plug it in if you
don't want it to there's also custom
charging limits there's also
pass-through charging there is no
wireless charging but there are two USBC
ports as I mentioned one on the bottom
and one on the side no it doesn't charge
twice as fast if you plug in both the
same time I tried that's still the
Legion phone dual little trick but uh
interestingly the the side USB port is
actually considered the primary one
that's the faster USB 3.1 data speeds so
either way if you plug in you can get
the fast charging but if you want to
plug in any accessories or anything like
that that will go into that side port
here but speaking of accessories this is
this is probably all you need to know
about how ridiculous this phone is and
who it's targeted for so this thing this
is the Aero active cooler 7. so this is
a clip-on
plug in active cooling accessory that
you plug into and connect to the back of
the phone that has a heatsink
fan RGB lights inside and this little uh
this black tab on the on the side of
this Rog phone
is actually an opening it motorizes and
opens up so you clamp on this cooler
over the side of the phone just like
this plug it in by the USB on the side
and the fan starts spinning up and then
this black like lift gate over here on
the side of the phone opens up to allow
active airflow through the side of the
phone it's opening up the phone and
spinning in that cool air so when you're
gaming this will help bring down the
back cover Surface by as much as 20 to
25 degrees Celsius according to Asus
Labs but there's also like there's four
trigger buttons back here there's RGB
lights that change and breathe depending
on what you're doing and there's a whole
subwoofer for enhanced bass and it
actually works
[Music]
[Applause]
there is a genuine Improvement in the
sound quality when listening to it with
the subwoofer on the back of the phone
and the front-facing speakers combined
you never expect these things to be as
good as they are but just the whole
thing just this this whole dedication to
building something that is going to take
a few degrees off your your phone and
give you a couple extra frames their
dedication to that gamer is impressive
it literally opens up the back of the
phone and by the way you can take this
off
and it closes that port on the back and
it's still ip54 water resistant when
it's closed this one feels like a sports
car where a lot of the ridiculous
specialized Tech is completely
unnecessary to most people but it'll
eventually trickle down into everyday
cars like most regular cars slash phones
don't need this crazy moving part and
active aerodynamics they don't need
extra RAM and extra power but eventually
eventually regular Flagship phones in a
few years will have all of this power
and all of this Cooling and all the
capabilities of this phone they'll just
be normal phones so make sure you
subscribe to see the reviews of those
phones when they come out but for now
this is this is still going to separate
itself as a phone for the gamer
especially just because of the way it's
built obviously it's thicker than a
normal phone but they they still have
things like bezels on the front for your
thumbs and the front-facing speakers so
you can hold it like this and have a
place when you're gaming to rest your
fingers
that's something most phones aren't
going to do anymore the X report of
course and the compatibility with the
crazy accessories and just their
willingness to just use like basic
off-the-shelf parts for the things that
don't really matter so much like sure
this Optical fingerprint reader
it's fine it's totally normal the
cameras as well like I said you don't
get a telephoto camera you just get like
an off-the-shelf B plus b camera system
fine but when it comes to anything that
a gamer could possibly want to get that
last one or two fps to get that last
second off of your lap time or that last
kill or to be able to have that little
bit of an advantage they'll throw the
kitchen sink at it they'll do all the
software features in the world and
Hardware stuff to make that happen and I
respect that there's no way I could go
through all those things in this single
video but I respect that a lot here are
some of my personal favorites there is a
new Vapor chamber cooling system inside
of this phone that you'll never see but
the new y-shaped Wick columns with
larger radii give a 168 percent
Improvement to Thermal efficiency
according to asus's testing the custom
mappable air triggers built into the top
corners of this phone have been improved
for better sensitivity and they can be
custom mapped for all kinds of stuff
even outside of games and this phone has
Wi-Fi 6E and Wi-Fi 7 support even though
none of our routers really do yet this
is a really impressive purpose-built
machine through and through I'm glad
they made it and uh yeah gaming phones
of today walk so that flagships of
Tomorrow can run
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]